so I got to tell you something something
really strange happened you see today I
was I was walking down the street and I
happened across some kids bullying
another kid and so naturally I stopped
and I started cheering and and I was
going yeah bully that kid bullying is
awesome
go bullying go bullying boys will be
boys but then some other men also joined
me and we were all just go we were all
going look at this bully this is some
great bullying actually it's a good
bullying in my day this is might be the
best bullying I've ever seen we were all
having that conversation but but just
then just then someone came up and they
showed me that Gillette ad and I
realized that that actually bullying is
wrong and my whole life has been changed
from the one in fact I I had I had it on
my schedule to to go after cheering on
the bullying I had it written down on my
schedule was gonna go stand on a street
corner and yell cat calls it women but I
swear I sing this video I went and I
crossed cat calls off my schedule just
crossed it right off and then I penciled
in ask women permission to compliment
them and and so that's what I did and
nobody gave me permission to compliment
them so now I have all these compliments
stored up and I've got and I've got so
that I just went to a tree and I started
complimenting the tree because I just I
had to compliment someone and this it
this is what it means to be a real man
okay anyway but seriously folks
seriously I did want to kind of follow
up on that on the conversation about the
Jillette ad you know we talked about
yesterday I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
rehash all my points I wanted to really
revisit one specific point and expand on
something that I mentioned yesterday
which is as we're talking about toxic
masculinity what about toxic femininity
okay we hear so much about toxic
masculinity what we don't hear about
toxic femininity and why is that
now as I said that's not a phrase that I
would really
ever use because femininity I know is
not toxic in fact what is what is often
toxic is when women reject their
femininity reject their womanhood just
as the toxic thing is when men reject
their masculinity and reject their
manhood
so femininity can no more be toxic than
can masculinity be toxic but in the
interests of fairness and the interest
of equality it seems to me that toxic
femininity should be a term and usage it
should be a term in fact that feminists
insist upon because they want everything
to be equal and toxic masculinity is a
term now I made this point yesterday and
some people said well no see that
doesn't make sense we can't talk about
toxic femininity because women don't do
all of the kinds of harmful things that
men do and and so women don't have I
even heard I heard many times in fact
worse the effect of women don't have the
capacity really to to hurt people and
and to harm Society and others the way
that men do is that really the case
though
well let's think about this for a moment
shall we
according to Gillette and to feminists
generally toxic masculinity is when men
are bullies when they harass assault
when they are pushy and presumptuous not
allowing women to speak and then of
course when they rape or when they
condone rape now I admit that as far as
rape goes that is more common
certainly more common among men than it
is among women men are certainly more
often the culprits in rape cases though
women do commit sexual assaults and it's
not it's not like they they they never
do it or it's so statistically rare that
it hardly even counts that that's not
the case at all especially these days
all you have to do is look at public
schools public school teachers often
females are assaulting their students
all the time hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of cases in recent years of of
schoolchildren being sexually assaulted
by their teachers and very often those
teachers are female so this sort of
thing does happen but still most cases
are men fine that's true but women have
other ways of causing damage okay women
have other ways of hurting people
especially when we're talking about
bullying and that was probably the most
absurd thing about the Gillette ad and
it's just the most absurd thing in
general when we're talking about
bullying and toxic masculinity no we're
lumping all these things together this
this this kind of like painting of
bullying as a uniquely male caused
problem which is absolutely ludicrous
girls and women bully people all the
time
and often female bullying takes a much
more insidious much more harmful form
just look at house girls in school treat
other girl
listen when you hear about these these
terrible cases of girls killing
themselves because of bullying and you
here are these cases all the time it's a
terrible thing but it's not usually boys
who were dude doing the bullying in
those cases it was girls and when you
hear about girls who have eating
disorders or who you know engage in
self-mutilation or other kinds of
self-harm again when you look at the
treatment that they are suffering in
school and what leads to these issues
it is almost always a girl-on-girl
problem now you know boys can be bullies
too but usually when a boy is gonna
bully you especially if he's bullying
another boy he'll insult you he'll call
you names usually to your face and or he
might say it behind your back too but
he'll also say it to your face and and
he might push you shove you punch you
right I mean this is the kind of thing
we're talking about it's pretty
straightforward is the point but what
girls will do to each other is is much
deeper much more damaging than that I
would say much more calculated they'll
gossip they'll spread rumors I mean
they're really gonna seek to destroy the
life of their victim just talk to some
women sometime who went through this in
in in school there are plenty of women
who their school careers were ruined
because of other girls and what other
girls said about them the rumors and
lies and and all that kind of stuff a
punch in the face hurts for a few
minutes but a destroyed reputation can
ruin your life now it just it seems odd
to me that somehow we miss this right
somehow when we're talking about the
challenges that women and girls face
we never point out that women and girls
are the primary bullies and poor mentors
of women and girls somehow we just leave
that out of the discussion
and by the way women can bully men also
and girls can bully boys that does
happen
not physically most of the time but but
it does happen in other ways emotional
and psychological ways a girl who is
higher on the social ladder than a boy
definitely has the ability to ridicule
mock embarrass him hurt him in many ways
there are plenty of boys who dread going
to school in part at least because of
how they're treated by girls in the
school and it's harder for them to in a
way because they can't really complain
about it because nobody will take the
complaint seriously and they can't
really do anything about it you know
when you're a boy and you're being
treated viciously by a bunch of girls in
school or something you know there's not
a lot you can really do if you start
shouting at them and screaming at them
then you're gonna look like the insane
person you're gonna seem like the bad
guy right and you know if it was if
you're a boy and there's another boy in
the school treating you that way then
for some boys the way you might handle
it is go up and punch him in the face
right but you know I couldn't do that
with a girl so you just most the time
endure it and and this stuff happens I
mean it happens all the time we don't
talk about it for some reason but it
does happen let's take something else
into consideration men do have certain
advantages over women certain things
that they can use to harm women and bad
men will use those things and the main
thing we're talking about here is
physical strength now this is brought up
all the time we're talking about toxic
toxic masculinity and so on and so forth
well men have this physical brute
strength which they can lord over women
and use against them and that's true it
does happen it's terrible but women have
their own advantages mainly they have
their sexuality and they have their
appearance and they have the desires of
men which they can manipulate and coerce
and they can use to sometimes destroy
people
this happens all the time that was one
of the things that was kind of lost in
the whole meet to hysteria because in
some of the K in plant you know in some
of the cases we heard about it was it
was pretty straightforward guy was being
the guy was being a pig being a jerk
being a predator victimizing women you
know or victimizing young boys and in
the case of Kevin Spacey so there were
some cases like that but there were also
plenty of cases where you looked at it
it was pretty apparent that the women
were also culpable in that they were
using their sexuality to obtain career
advancements not just that either but if
a man approaches a woman tries to talk
to her tries to initiate something and
he does it respectfully well the woman
if she's a jerk if she's a pig if she's
a bad person she has the ability in that
moment now that the man has made himself
vulnerable to her he has the ability to
she has the ability to completely
embarrass and humiliate him and there
are some women who will do that
that they will take that vulnerability
and they'll just crush you with it right
and this is the kind of thing that
single men have to deal with
which is one of the many reasons why I'm
I'm very happy that I'm not single but
there's something single mints is one of
the things single men worry about you
know they worry about if you're if
you're you know if they sit back and
they never initiate they never go try to
talk to a woman well then they're just
gonna be single for us they're alive and
they're gonna die alone so they know
that because even with all of the
changes in society and everything it's
still expected that the man is going to
initiate and women expect it even if
they complain when some guy they don't
like initiates they still expect the
initiation happen on the part of men men
know that but they also know that if
they try to initiate the try to strike
up a conversation they try to get
something going again respectfully you
know
consensually they know they they just
made themselves vulnerable and if the
woman wants to if she's a bad person she
could destroy you maybe not destroy you
permanently but she could crush you in
that moment
and embarrass you or as we've seen other
cases she could actually destroy you if
she decides to make up a lie make up a
rape claim and these things also happen
the point here is that all of these
issues
bullying harassing abusing all these all
these issues they are much bigger much
more complex than how they're painted
and when we are determined to make men
the bad guys and women the good guys and
to end to kind of position the issue in
that black and white way
talk about the reverse scenarios where
the woman's a bad guy then a lot of
victims including female victims are
ignored because their bully their
harasser their predator their abuser was
a female and that doesn't count
apparently because nobody wants to talk
about that nobody wants to talk about
the times when women act terribly
just look you talk to uh talk to a
teacher' sometime talk like a middle
school teacher a high school teacher and
they'll tell you about they'll tell you
about the just evil behavior on a part
of some not all of course but some girls
just guy just evil to each other in a
way that far surpasses what what guys
will do this is not I know anytime you
you know you try to bring this up
someone's gonna say well that's what
about ISM that's what about ISM you know
no you can't do what about we're talking
about men right now so for you to try to
bring in bring up women that's your
deflecting your obfuscating you're
trying to avoid well the the what about
ISM claim the what about ISM accusation
is about the laziest way to handle an
argument these days because here's the
problem it's really easy to say well you
know no no we're not talking about women
we're talking about men right now okay
so you can't change the subject
yeah but we're always talking about men
that's the point we only ever talk about
the things that the the bad things that
men do there is never a time when
everyone's going to agree to okay you
know what let's let's talk about let's
move the conversation forward let's
focus on women for a minute that will
never happen it never does happen the
conversation when it comes to bullying
harassing abusing all of that it is
always 100 percent of the time about men
so if we're ever going to bring women
into this conversation to and look at
the whole picture and look at every
facet of the problem then somebody's
gonna have to go well what about and so
yes i am doing a what about because you
know what i think we've covered men at
this point like we get it we've covered
it we know we understand it's been
established we are it's it totally is
100 percent establish everybody knows
now there are bad terrible men out there
who do bad table that we get it we know
yes thank you okay can we talk about
this over here now
all right once you
want to mention another thing I wanted
to talk about this because it's a great
example of how identity politics leads
to insanity so there's been a lot of
belly aching recently because in the NFL
there have been several head coaching
vacancies over this during the offseason
which has only been for a few weeks and
those opportunities so far has been I
don't know I think it's been seven or
eight seven or eight head coaching
vacancies so far in the last few weeks
and in all but one of the cases I
believe the opportunities have gone to
white coaches and this is a source of
constant outrage the perceived lack of
black head coaches and it's one of the
reasons why or the reason why the NFL
came up with the Rooney Rule and the
Rooney rule requires that teams have to
interview black candidates for coaching
jobs no matter what even if a team knows
who it wants for its coach which is the
case plenty of times you know where
they've already made their decision
there's someone out there who know they
know they want because he fits with the
scheme he fits with what the team is
doing and the program and everything
else but even in those cases says the
Rooney rule you got to bring in a black
coach and interview him anyway just for
show even though there's no chance he's
gonna get the job which of course is
insulting to the black coach and it's
just generally stupid and demeaning and
pointless and that's when you try to
institute identity politics and make it
into a policy you're always going to end
up with generally stupid and demeaning
and pointless and insulting things but
now that a bunch of teams have had the
audacity in the last few weeks to hire
the person that they think is best for
the job rather than the person who feels
a certain racial quota the left is is
really upset and now they're saying that
the Rooney rule isn't enough and now
there need to be more procedures put in
place to make sure that a certain
arbitrary percentage of head coaching
vacancies go to black men or or not just
black I mean I'm sure
love a black woman or any sort of woman
forever to become an NFL head coach let
me read it just as an example of this
outrage let me read an article from
Yahoo Sports written by a guy by the
name of Torres Baylor we a little bit of
it it says Eric the enemy stood and
smiled in front of the Kansas City
Chiefs press corps last Wednesday
he spoke deliberately and passionately
with pauses in between as if you are a
well-spoken professor or a preacher days
earlier no fewer than five NFL teams
expressed interest in interviewing the
Chiefs offensive coordinator for a head
coaching job he took many of those
interviews and given his upbeat weekly
news conference it seemed like he landed
one of the three remaining jobs of
market alas one day later the New York
Jets hired former Miami head coach Adam
GaSe to be their new leader and one day
after that news trickled out that the
Cincinnati Bengals were leaning toward
hiring Los Angeles Rams quarterback
coach Zack Taylor while the Miami
Dolphins were hiring someone else
assuming the Taylor Flores hires will
become official when their team season's
end he will bring an end to another head
coaching cycle that was surprisingly
rough for BN the enemy and other top my
own minority coaches of the eight new
head coach is hired by NFL teams over
the past two weeks only Flores a
Brooklyn born son of Honduran immigrants
is a man of color Flores and then under
the header it says a statistical step
back and it says Flores will join Mike
Tomlin of the Pittsburgh Steelers Ron
Riviera Rivera of the Carolina Panthers
and Anthea Lin of the Los Angeles
charges as the only minority head
coaches in the league to start the 2019
season that's half the high-water mark
of eight that was in place at the start
of the 2018 season on the surface this
is a step back one that isn't a great
look for the NFL and Commissioner Roger
Goodell
who has made it a goal to increase front
office and coaching staff diversity in a
league of players that is approximately
70% black and then it goes on with so on
and so forth
this is
this is just so cynical and and insane
and racist honestly a statistical step
back what does that even mean a
statistical way based on what like what
what is the statistic we're aiming for
and who decided that statistic it's
completely arbitrary as it always is
with these affirmative action type
things it's just totally off just we
just decided that you know what there
should be a certain amount of people
with this ethnic background in this job
why because just because and if that
means that there are perfectly qualified
people who don't get a job well then
fine because the statistics are what we
must all bow before the statistics I
mean think about it you've got you know
six or seven white guys that were hired
to coach team very qualified some of
these guys you know they're hired for a
reason very good at what they do and so
that's why they were hired and then so
now this Perez or Torres Baylor he comes
along as well that's a statistical step
back how would you like it if you you
know you you get a job that you've
earned and you've been working towards
and then someone comes along and calls
it a statistical step back and when you
complain that there should be more black
head coaches what you're saying is that
there's a white head coach or maybe a
few of them in the league right now who
shouldn't have a job that's what you're
saying and so which one is that point
them out three which of the head coaches
I would challenge the person who wrote
this article whoever else supports his
Rooney Rule stuff which of the white
head coaches would you fire just so that
you could replace him with someone with
darker skin and are you gonna go explain
that to his family by the way like go go
sit down with his wife his kids and say
hey listen he's been working for this he
he fits the job he's doing a good job
but what he's gonna have to go
because we've got statistics that we
need to take into consideration here but
the thing and this is this is why this
really jumps out of me and the writer of
this article he even points this out and
it's but this is he points it out as if
it under lines his own point but really
it undermines this point and that is
that there are a great many minorities
in the NFL a great many minorities who
are paid very very well to do their job
and that if we're looking at statistics
and you were to compare you know
percentage-wise how many black people
are in America percentage-wise versus
how they're represented in the NFL you
would say statistically they're way way
way over represented in the NFL I mean
if we're doing this random arbitrary
thing with head coaches where we're
looking at the racial disparity and
we're saying oh there's too many white
people well why don't we do the reverse
with cornerbacks why don't we do the
reverse with running backs or or or
linebackers or wide receivers or free
safeties in all of those cases you're
gonna find that almost all of them are
black people who again are in very
visible positions being paid very well
very handsomely for doing their job and
why are they in those positions why are
they being paid so well because they're
extremely good at what they do so I'm
not gonna complain no I wouldn't I
wouldn't say oh no they're the other
that we need to get some more white
people into wide receiver positions I
can I mean there are a few white wide
receivers in a league only a few
including one very good one but I
I gotta say that oh no we need to get
more because why right now if you're a
wide receiver if you're if you're on a
team if you're if you if you're stuff if
you're on a roster as a wide receiver
the NFL it's because you're just really
good it's because you're one of the best
at doing that in the entire world you're
one of the best athletes in the world
and that's how you got on that roster
and it does not matter what your race is
and if we look and we say well you know
it looks like 95% of wide receivers are
black well it's just because they happen
to be the ones that are the best that's
why they have the job good for them
great nothing to be upset about
but it just seemed it seems so
especially absurd to start playing this
identity politics game with the NFL of
all or the NBA
of all things because those are examples
of extremely a talented gifted often
minority people who are doing a job and
getting paid a lot of money a lot more
money than the new where I get paid and
yet we're still finding a reason to
complain because we say oh yeah well
they're they're really represented there
in that position and in that position
that position that position in that
position that position that position oh
wait but there's a position where
they're not as well represented so let's
focus on that
why who cares why does it matter now
listen if you could find an example in
in modern times of a black coaching
candidate who was deprived of a job
because of his skin color then then I
would agree well that's a problem I mean
that's racist so if you could find an
example if you could present anything
like evidence to support the idea that
for instance the the coaching candidate
that was mentioned at the beginning of
this article was denied those positions
because the NFL owners were racist and
didn't want a black guy taking up those
positions well then you've got a case on
you know then you've got a then you can
make a case
but that's not what's happening
and in fact what you're doing is you're
demanding exactly that sort of thing but
in the reverse
you're demanding that there be white
people who are deprived of position
because of the color of their skin which
is obviously clearly racist
and the thing that just annoys me the it
annoys me in general with this kind of
stuff it annoys me even more when it
when you when you start injecting it
into sports because one of the great
things about smih the reason why I like
sports the reason why even you know
increasingly I really enjoy just sitting
down and watching a game of some kind is
because usually that's where all this
identity politics and all this you
usually hopefully until recently anyway
you you all that stuff goes to the side
because on the field or on the court
it's really just about whoever's best
wins it's just like mono e mono team
vers team and if you're the best at
doing it then you win and that's it
there are no other considerations taken
into account
that's what's great about it in a world
or wakhan in a culture where we're
constantly measuring and judging and
politicizing and you know quantifying
things and coming up with quotas and
everything it's great to be able to just
sit down and watch like a football game
and you know that look if this team has
better athletes and they've got a better
game plan they're gonna win doesn't
matter it doesn't matter what the racial
makeup is none of that matters they're
gonna win but the left says no they
can't a lot they cannot allow there to
be any kind of oasis in our culture
where their social engineering and their
political agenda does not affect they
can't allow it and so now they're gonna
focus on sports do and that is a cryin
cryin shame we will leave it there
thanks for watching and listening
Godspeed